c'est un rêve pour beaucoup que de venir
passer les fêtes de fin d'année à saint
pétersbourg et pourtant la situation
sanitaire est particulièrement délicate
dans sept régions de russie la situation
à saint pétersbourg est compliqué mais
sous contrôle
néanmoins le soutien du centre fédéral
et la coopération avec l'oblast de
leningrad nous ont donné de tels
résultats que nous tenons bon de manière
générale mais je fais toujours appel aux
habitants de la ville
la pandémie et la lutte contre la
pandémie relève de la responsabilité
mutuelle des autorités de l'état et des
habitants les autorités promulguer des
lois organise le processus de traitement
mais les citoyens doivent également
respecter les règles prescrites par le
rose poudré de noces d'or
résultat les autorités locales ont
adopté des mesures assez radical comparé
au reste du pays du 30 décembre au 3
janvier
bars et restaurants sont fermés à la
clientèle alors qu'ils étaient jusque-là
ouverts jusqu'à 19 heures même chose
pour les théâtres et les musées
cette année très dure pour le secteur de
la restauration
il ya normalement beaucoup de clients
dans les restaurants et partout surtout
pendant les jours fériés les gens
affluent peut-être que les restrictions
contribueront à limiter l'augmentation
du nombre des cas mais en même temps la
restauration est durement frappée cette
année cette période est assez difficile
puisque nous venons de sortir de la
crise du printemps lors de laquelle nous
n'avons pas travaillé durant trois mois
et maintenant nous sommes autorisés à
travailler au moins comme ça franchement
nous sommes reconnaissants au moins pour
cette période
néanmoins pas de quoi entamer la bonne
humeur et l'enthousiasmé de la
population alors que se profilent les
fêtes du noël russe
on ira chez les parents de ma petite
amie apps cov et fêteront le nouvel an
en famille nous avons tous à la fête à
la maison en famille
nous avons deux enfants on restera chez
nikko cette année le navire fera
personnes et nous n'irons nulle part à
cause du coronavirus oui on a peur
la pandémie de qovu 19 que traverse le
monde ne touche pas la russie de façon
uniforme les autorités ajuste donc les
mesures à prendre en fonction du
contexte sanitaire locale
à l'heure actuelle c'est probablement à
saint pétersbourg que les mesures sont
les plus restrictifs